Rock of Ages is a movie based off the
Broadway play you know it's a lot of
classic music and it's set to a story
and it uses classic rock songs to form
some kind of a story and it starts with
a love story it's Julianne Hough and
Diego Bonet - yeah he's a guy and
Julianne Hough is hot that's all I need
to know they're in Hollywood they're
both trying to make it in the music
industry they can both sing they both
have their ideas for bands and stuff
like that they work at the Bourbon Alec
Baldwin and Russell Brand managed the
Bourbon paul giamatti is a manager of
Stacee Jaxx who's like the hardest
rocker who ever lived played by Tom
Cruise and Catherine zeta-jones is the
woman who is against rock and wants to
crush it and just bring it to the ground
so this musical takes place in 1987 you
know you got people with the crazy hair
and the jeans and just the outfits and
the whole aura of 1987 this movie really
captures it I've never really been a big
fan of musicals in fact if I had to pick
a genre that was my least favorite I'd
probably say musicals that being said I
had a blast with this movie it was a lot
of fun if you like this type of music if
you like classic rock like this and you
don't mind other people covering it and
covering it well then you probably
really enjoy Rock of Ages it is
seriously a blast it's impossible to go
to this movie with that attitude of like
what do you think might take place in
this feature film Jim hmm I will be
eyeing this film seriously Jim I'm not
sure about this one this is this is a
little bit too much fun this is I'm
feeling like I might be having fun
and I've been one to explode about this
I've been trying to hold it off
seriously guys Tom Cruise makes this
movie the ticket price of this movie is
worth it alone just to see Tom Cruise do
his rendition of pour some sugar on me
he honestly makes this entire movie I
was having some fun with the movie you
know I was having some fun with it the
first 20 minutes or so as soon as his
character is introduced it just
catapults to a completely different
level he's funny in this film he is
incredibly good with the rocking he is
so convincing as a rock star seriously
it is awesome say what you will about
Tom Cruise he is one of the most
dedicated actors working today I mean no
one hangs from sides of buildings in
Dubai and does the kind of crap he's
doing in this movie he is so good here
his character has one of the
introductions I've seen for a character
in a while he literally rises out from
under a sea of women I was electrified
by crews in this movie it was like pure
just adrenaline rush every time he was
on the screen he made this movie so much
better than it could have been I liked
the music they had in this movie if I've
had great song choices journey Guns and
Roses you know a lot of great songs
classic rock and if you like that kind
of music you'll probably enjoy this
movie if you don't then you probably
shouldn't see the movie because it's
obviously watching music you're not
gonna like I mean it make sense to me
julianne hough dear lord i mean she is
stunning in this movie there were a lot
of scenes in this movie where i just
kind of audibly went oh she's good in
the movie she's she's good also I had a
lot of fun with Malin Akerman
performance - I thought she did a really
nice job now the lead boy Diego Boneta I
don't know he was fine he was okay the
lead romance story of the film was a
little cheesy but the thing is it is
going for the cheese like you know
that's gonna be cheesy it's just it is
cheesy it's a late eighties rock musical
it's gonna be cheesy Bryan Cranston is
also in this film he's married to
Catherine zeta-jones I love him but
honestly I didn't really feel the need
for his character to be in the film his
character didn't really bring anything
to the movie I loved seeing Cranston in
anything I mean I think he's a terrific
actor but his character just didn't
really seem to fit in the film and
Catherine zeta-jones was really over the
top in the movie I know her character is
supposed to be and basically everything
in his movie is over-the-top but
something about her just didn't seem
right either that side of the story was
a little bit weak and I thought it was a
little poorly told and this is just a
little net pick from a directing
standpoint a lot of the shots seem like
the camera was very far away and they
zoomed in a lot and I was like let's get
some more actual close-ups and more
tracking shots some more panning shots
long takes you know I would have been
nice but for the most part this movie is
directed with really high energy I was
extremely surprised how much fun I had
with this movie see it for Cruz alone he
honestly makes this movie his character
of Stacee Jaxx when you combine that
with Len Grossman this guy is honestly
doing supporting roles that just
overtake the whole movie I'm going to
give Baraka pages a B+ it's a lot of fun
if you like this classic rock they'll
probably enjoy the movie if you'd like
the actors you probably enjoy it as well
but if you can't take the cheese a
musical that takes place in the 80s then
just stay away I also want to make a
little announcement here if you guys saw
the schmoes know review of the new TV
show arrow then you saw the schmoes
announced that them and I are going to
be
elaborating on a six-part series
reviewing the previous Batman films
before Dark Knight Rises comes out in
July to look forward to that soon that
very first review is going to be for the
1989 Batman and that's going to be on
the schmoes Channel soon stay tuned for
that and as always guys if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]